Hello there.
I'm Gov.
I'm Dan.
And this slow-mo video is
another one about car safety.
We did airbags.
This is a seatbelt pre tensioner.
Yeah, So I've got one type here
which uses a preloaded spring.
What's gonna happen is when
you crash this loaded
spring gets released putting
on a cable here,
which is attached your seat seatbelt
and that pulls the seatbelt
down.
Then pulling you into your seat.
So you're more...
Kind of stops the bottom half
of you from sliding away.
Yeah.
This one uses a spring.
This one uses explosives.
So I'm more excited about
this one to be honest.
We'll get this one out the way
and then move on to the explosives
and it's gonna fire from here.
So I think we should
load this up with paint.
We could put something in that, sure.
Yeah, we're gonna film
this with two cameras.
One is the Phantom Flex 4k
for a maximum resolution.
Resolution.
And for speed,
we're gonna use the Phantom V2511
which we're shooting at
28,000 frames per second.
Speed.
Ready?
Yeah.
[Clicking]
You put it in the tree.
This was too weak to pull it.
Goodness sake.
All right, I guess we're
not doing that one.
We've moved on to the explosive one.
Cause the spring one,
we couldn't set it off.
Get some paint in this one, you think?
Yeah.
All right, loading up with red paint.
Well...
Ready? And go.
[Click]
It went...
It's rapid that,
that was very fast.
Really quick.
God man.
Let's get that one.
Yeah.
It's just so quick,
Isn't it?
That was a great blood gun.
Yeah, I'm glad we used the
foster camera cause yeah.
That hardly showed anything
Because it was rapid.
Yeah.
Alright Let's see.
This shows a lot more.
This is amazing.
How much I believe it's 20,000 frames.
A second.
That's too short.
It literally just
you see the puff of the
explosive smoke coming
out the back.
And you can just see
the smoke on this one.
Yeah.
That's so clear.
And this is the blood
gun looks even better.
That was really quick
Wasn't it?
smells good.
Yeah, I was gonna say you can
really smell the explosive
That's goods.
I am always blown away
by the amount of explosives
that are sat in a car.
Just ready to save your
life with airbags and these.
They're like raring together,
That seems like.
it's so cool.
Do you know the ejector seats
on planes have explosives
in them all around the edge?
Yeah.
That's they get blown up quickly.
We should do one of them.
yeah.
We shoot you up.
That's a really interesting video.
That was cool.
I have more trust in cars now.
Yeah.
Whenever you enjoyed that
feel free to follow us on Twitter.
Subscribe to the channel.
There's loads of videos.
Buy a shirt.
You look better in slow mo.
That's pretty much it.
We'll see you next time.
See that broken down.
I was filming that.
What just happened?
I just dropped it and it broke.